okay everyone i think that we have uh
most of our
participants back um
so prasad i think we can go ahead and
start with a talk from lightningtop from
our research fellow all right uh i hope
you had a good networking break now
we'll have our fellows give lightning
talks
uh i'd like to start with the first uh
fellow uh anurag anshu will be giving
their first lightning talk
oh episode
uh yeah let me quickly shut the screen
uh well wrong slide sorry
yeah
okay so uh this talk will be about
our learnability of hamiltonians from
quantum anybody give states this is a
joint work with
srinivasan to mataga and mehdi
which was which came last year
so um the central object of our
discussion in this talk will be
uh quantum many body systems which are a
collection of particles
let's say a collection of qubits and so
on
which interact locally
so
uh a hamiltonian looks like a sum of
terms uh
where mu's are some real numbers they're
between minus one and one
which reflects the fact that there are
no very strong interactions in nature
at a local level
and these are some operators so for
example uh ease could be four qubit
bodies
which is shown in this picture and each
placket corresponds to a poly
so that's our setup it's a hamiltonian
that describes the that governs
properties of the system
so a gibbs state is a special quantum
state that is derived from a hamiltonian
which essentially is exponential in
h up to a factor which is called inverse
temperature
and z is a is a factor which normalizes
the
the quantum state
the goal here is that given independent
samples from
the gibbs state
where the
terms mu are unknown can i figure out
what mu is that is can i figure out mu
prime which is a vector of n numbers
which approximates mu
so this is the problem of uh learning
the hamiltonian because the parameters
knew specify the hamiltonian
there are several motivations why i
wouldn't want to figure out this and
solve this problem
so well very broadly learning the
hamiltonian is the first step towards
predicting properties of physical system
so things like
spectral gap of hamiltonian the
structure of the lattice and so on they
play a very important role in the
physics of the system and also uh
in in statistical machine learning uh
graphical models are very important
objects which which are the classical
analogs of this problem and they're very
widely studied
in very complex materials there's
something known as an effective
hamiltonian which
uh governs the interaction between
coarse grained particles and they can be
very hard to understand unless one
really tries to learn them uh and in
fact some hamiltonians even go on the
entanglement properties
so learning them is a very natural task
to figure out what the environment looks
like
more recently in quantum algorithms uh
uh
gibbs states play a very important role
and uh
uh verifying that my quantum system is
producing the right gibbs state is uh is
an important task in designing quite
a quantum computers
uh finally uh gibbs states can also
approximate quantum states at low
temperature
and
uh
if you learn gibbs states then we can
also learn other quantum states
so our result is an algorithm that out
that solves this problem with a number
of samples that's polynomial in the
number of particles and this is also
tied up to a factor of six
uh so there's a lot of scope for
improvement and algorithm is pretty
simple because it performs some small
measurements on the quantum state
followed by classical cross processing
it's time efficient in some cases which
is the classical processing part
uh i can quickly tell you about the
learning strategy uh in the next one
minute um
so uh
it turns out that in the quantum context
or even in the classical context the
gradient of the quantum partition
function is something that can be
physically observed so here is a picture
of the quantum partition function
and
here is a gradient and we would like to
find the point you start but experiments
only reveal an approximate gradient
there's a red line over here
so there's an error in
the value of mu that you would like
and the key point is that if the quantum
partition function curves fast enough
then new prime can't be that far away
from mu
mu star and that's our goal so we show
essentially that uh the quantum
partition function has this property
that it's very convex everywhere that
means uh it curves pretty well enough
and that is captured by what is known as
the hessian of the partition function
and we show that it's pretty large
it's not large enough uh
compared to classical results where
there's no factor of one over m but
that's fine for our applications uh
improving this m would also improve the
power bombs and classically these
results are easy to prove because what
is known as a
markov condition which is uh or
conditional independence is very well
studied classically it's very well known
but that totally fails in the quantum
world so that's why proving these
results is hard so uh that's the main
technical result and uh up to the future
work
so the the big open question here is to
figure out optimal sample and time
complexity for all temperatures for this
problem
we know so far commuting hamiltonians uh
can be learned optimally and also high
temperature states can be learned
optimally
and and the next question once we figure
out this probably would be to understand
the learnability of other important
quantum states such as tennessee
networks and quantum circuits as i added
earlier they would be closely needed to
get states and that's about it thanks
for your attention
uh thank you
uh any questions for anurag while
stephen bates sets up
all right
the next speaker is stephen bates
all right
um
hello i'm going to be talking about
learn then test it's a framework for
giving confidence intervals for deep
learning models among other things
i should say this is a joint work with
some great collaborators anastasios
emmanuel mike and lewis who are all
at stanford berkeley and involved with
the science institute in various ways
okay
okay so the setting for kind of this um
this talk or this method is the
following so we have a lot of really
great predictive models
um in the modern world to do things like
image processing text processing and so
on um but they're often very complex
right so if i want to use a
state-of-the-art computer vision model
uh it's going to have hundreds of layers
and be very you know millions or
billions of parameters and be very
challenging to understand in a sort of
brute force way
um when i deploy something like this i
still need to talk about uncertainty or
statistical performance right i can't
just deploy it use my point predictions
and then pretend i'm getting
great results all the time so what am i
going to do in a setting like this
okay so that's what we're going to um
that's why we introduced this learn and
test
algorithm or framework so it has
basically three steps you start off with
some model f hat and so this is going to
be a deep learning model say okay you
can get it with any architecture any
optimizer whatever you want it's some
black box that we're then going to kind
of probe to
extract
rigorous confidence intervals
okay so if i'm doing classification i
want confidence interval step two is
going to be parameterizing a family of
possible confidence intervals and i'm
going to parameterize it by this
parameter lambda you should think of it
as a one-dimensional parameter okay so
on top of my deep learning model i have
one parameter that goes from small
intervals to big intervals and i'm going
to figure out where i need to be to get
valid confidence intervals okay
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
choose that final parameter that one
small parameter on top of the network
via multiple testing so that you can get
rigorous statistical guarantees about
the output
okay so let's make this concrete in the
case of classification so i'm going to
start here with some model f hat
f hat is again something like a resnet
or any deep learning model and let's say
it spits out soft max scores for each
class like i'll say that there's k
classes here one to k okay
i can i can kind of hypothesize a set of
reasonable confidence intervals or
confidence sets in this case because the
output is discrete as follows i'm going
to take all the classes y where the soft
max score this kind of estimated soft
max score exceeds some threshold lambda
okay so i'm going to pick the top
classes all the classes that have
probability exceeding lambda for some
lambda this is kind of a set of possible
confidence sets indexed by this
parameter lambda
okay and i'm going to choose that lambda
to get 90 coverage how do i do that i
look at some fresh data
okay i kind of make a plot for
different values of this lambda what is
the coverage i see on fresh data so
coverage here means what fraction of my
confidence intervals or my confidence
sets actually contain the true label
okay i just plot that i look at that
number and i see where it hits 90
or if i wanted 90 coverage i see where
it hits 90
now
i'm
glossing over some of the details i
don't use exactly 90 you have to adjust
this based on statistical fluctuations
but there's a kind of a a small constant
here that you increase
in order to make this all statistically
valid but morally what you do is you're
just going to use some fresh data to
tune the confidence intervals to have 90
observed coverage okay so again this is
the point i see on my little bit of
extra data where i got the right
coverage and i'm going to deploy that
value of lambda on future data
okay so that now is my confidence set
function going forward
okay so now the magic here is that we
have a precise statistical guarantee
with high probability um you'll have at
least 90 coverage on future data and
this this statement is agnostic to the
true distribution of the data or the
network you started with and so on so
it's it's not assuming anything about
the distribution or your model and so on
and this delta here the small
probability constant you get to pick
that uh you know i can pick it to be say
one percent
okay
um i'll refer you to the paper for all
the details but uh again this is um
you you're tuning this low dimensional
parameter in order to get the correct
confidence intervals i should say that
in this particular setting with
confidence intervals there is previous
work that we're building on here what i
find most exciting about this is that
you can do basically anything now so
i'll show you an example from objects
detection in object detection you have
um you're given an image like the one on
the left and you have in this case three
goals you want to identify distinct
objects you want to segment them or find
the pixels corresponding to that object
and then you want to classify them okay
there are kind of error rates associated
with these criteria so i want to kind of
have high recall i want to find most of
the objects i want to have good
segmentation so i want to have high
intersection over union with the real
masks and i want to have good coverage i
want to find the right class most of the
time it turns out with this algorithm
this three-step algorithm i showed you
before you can do that here's a quick
simulation experiment where you can see
you have good coverage you have good iou
and you have good recall because you
pick the parameters in this way
okay
all right so i'll conclude with that
um
okay my screen stopped updating but
that's okay i'll wrap up with that
thanks very much for your attention and
i'd love to take any last questions you
have
thanks stephen any questions for stephen
while see that sets up
i don't see any
all right
i can ask a question uh stephen hey at
cindy um so are you assuming like uh
with your fresh data you have to be able
to do some sort of like hold out a
validation set or something right so
we're assuming like supervised
yeah yeah it's supervised exactly so
there has to be ground truth data with
uh say the real labels yeah
okay awesome thanks
nick speaker
yeah hi thanks uh
thanks prasad and thanks everyone for uh
coming to the talk so i'll be talking
about how we can use exact sampling to
get better samples
and uh
oh i think one second
okay so
this is really more like a meta
statement i want to make about when we
have some local procedure to sample
approximately
uh can we do something to ensure better
quality of samples
but let me give you an example to sort
of uh
make what i'm saying more concrete so
let's take
this famous hardcore model that we all
study in statistical physics uh which is
essentially just a model for sampling
independent sets
so you have
a graph
of some max degree delta and each vertex
can either be
configurations where no two neighbors
are occupied it is essentially the
independent set
in this graph and each independent set
is assigned a probability proportional
to lambda uh to the power its size so
lambda here is the fugacity parameter
which controls uh the kind of
distribution we are looking for if
lambda is
1 we are essentially looking at the
uniform distribution of independent sets
if
lambda is
large then we are preferring the higher
the
independence
sets which are larger in size
and
this is used to model the behavior of
heart spheres uh in statistical physics
but it has been a classical uh uh
playground for studying uh various
sampling algorithms in tcs uh and stats
uh statistical physics so
the local changes we make here are
is the popular logo dynamics which works
on the space of all independent sets and
it works in this very simple way which i
guess many of us know and just very
quickly chooses a random vertex so given
an independent set i it chooses a random
vertex and it chooses a random number x
and then depending on whether it can uh
update a uh so let's say that it can
update the randomly chosen vertex to be
occupied then it does so with
probability lambda or one plus lambda if
it can't in cases it chooses the vertex
a there is no way to update the vertex a
to b one because there is already a
neighbor of a which is one if it can't
then it just uh keeps it to be empty and
if it can then it's probably lambda 1
plus lambda it updates the vertex to be
1 like in case it chooses b so it's a
very simple uh random process which is
very local and we keep on applying it
again and again and hopefully the idea
is that after some time we will get
close to the distribution we want which
is the stationary distribution of the
chain so then if we can do that why are
we interested in doing something more
than this so one of the big issues here
is
that firstly
uh you need if you're going to use this
procedure in practice you you need some
guarantee on the sample quality
and uh usually this requires proving
mixing time bounce which is not very
easy and even if you suck
succeed uh using a lot of cleverness to
prove a mixing time bound
uh the given instance uh that
you are running that
unless you either you have to rely on
heuristics or
uh the other option is just running it
for the
time steps
uh larger than the actual mixing time
use this framework of exact sampling
like besides being elegant and
interesting it also provides you with a
stopping time criteria so
the the it sort of turns the table in a
different way it says that look i don't
know how long the algorithm will run but
whenever it stops the quality of the
sample is never suspect so it can sort
of get uh this advantage you know that
on your use case the running time might
be much slower and it's not like a
heuristic argument saying that or the
sample quality if it
meets some statistics is going to be
good it is sort of like a mathematical
guarantee that the sample quality is
exactly what you want it to be
so to give you a sample of what actually
happens in this uh kind of arguments so
like if we take the previous global
dynamics we study with very little
minimal uh
with very little extra work we are able
to produce a sample which is exactly
according to the distribution we want
rather than uh having to run it for the
given number of time steps uh and doing
a mixing time bound so it basically
works by this idea of sandwiching you
use two different chains and you run the
global dynamics on those individual
chains so you can see that i have two
chains here top and bot and they are not
independent the top
chain is not an independent set but
that's okay
and you you run the global dynamics
update on both the chains uh using some
joint coupling or something and you will
get two different chains and then you
add an extra rule of swapping so this is
the part where we need to design some
cleverness into the algorithm and you
swap the updated vertices so in this
case the vertex b was updated
so you you
swap the state swap step every time you
use the global dynamic step and when
morally when these two chains become
equal
morally when these two chain
is become equal
because that is the states become the
same then we can
and we can stop that and you can see
that with very little extra work we
don't have to worry about the quality of
our sampling process
uh as in
uh final slide i thought i'll show some
graphs which demonstrates the amount of
steps we need
in terms of the size of the graph until
these two chains the top and what chains
coalesce
so
for delta equal to four
uh
and delta equal to five so these are
random regular graphs of degree four and
degree five the number of steps roughly
goes like
a linear or close to n log n kind of
function
uh
and this is what we expect and delta
equal to 6 we know
you know that this
problem sort of is already hot see the
cola sometimes it's possible to take
advantage of fast mixing without
actually being able to prove it and
thanks that's all i'll leave you with
this slide
thanks adapt
the next speaker is a spencer frey
yes
okay can everyone see my screen and hear
me yes
great okay uh so the this talk is called
proxy convexity unified framework for
the analysis of neural network stream by
creating a descent
and it's joined to work with chon chong
gu who was my supervisor back at ucla um
so just to jump right into it um this
this talk is about neural network
optimization
and as i'm sure everyone is familiar
with neural network objectives or
non-convex um and there's a number of
hardness results that specifically show
that there is no in many settings
there's no hope for finding global
minima for these objective functions but
yet what we observe in practice is that
gradient descent seems to be pretty good
at finding good local minima maybe
they're not global minima but they're
better than what my one might expect
naively
and so the difficulty of trying to
understand this problem from a
non-convex optimization perspective
is that most non-convex optimization
frameworks uh exist in this setting
where all local minima are global um and
so
the kind of motivation for this work is
to to try to uh design
uh new non-convex optimization uh kind
of definitions or frameworks that allow
for characterizations of these types of
optimization problems
so we introduced a number of definitions
i'm going to in the paper
i'm just going to focus on this this one
definition
just due to time constraints um and it's
this is this definition of proxy
convexity um so we say that a function
is gh proxy convex
if this type of inequality holds
where the way to think about this
inequality is that you know standard
convexity is that the function lies
above its first order taylor
approximation
um proxy convexity relaxes that to say
that perhaps the function f doesn't lie
above its own first order taylor
approximation
but that there is some proxy function h
that does lie above it and perhaps
instead of
starting that first order taylor
approximation at f itself we shift it
down to start at some function g
um so this is a very general and
abstract definition that can accommodate
very poorly behaved and non-convex h f
and g
and the type of result that one gets
if you have this proxy convexity
property is that gradient descent on the
objective f will eventually find points
where g
is at least as small as the best
possible value for h
so this is very general and in order for
this to be meaningful for the original
optimization problem for f
of course h and g need to be related to
f in some way
and just to kind of go through a quick
example of what that might actually look
like in an example of a neural network
optimization problem
is just considering this single neuron
problem where you have just a single
non-linearity sigma and the squared loss
and what we can show is that in this
setting a form of proxy complexity holds
where this proxy function g
is like the squared loss with this sigma
prime term attached
and the proxy loss h is something like
the absolute value loss or the square
root of the original
optimus objective um
and so in this setting you know what our
kind of textbook guarantee for proxy
convexity says is that because this
proxy convexity is holds
we'll eventually find some point where g
is at least as small as the best
possible value of h
and so what that essentially means is
that sgd will find points with that is
not the global minimum but like the
square root of the global minimum value
up to some constant
and there are a number of hardness
results which say that we you know we
can't uh hope to find the global minimum
and so this really captures like uh in a
in a concrete way this setting where
global minima is hard but sgd finds good
local minimum
and so something that i think uh is
an interesting future direction which i
haven't really explored and i'd love to
talk with people
uh who are
attending about
is kind of reverse engineering this um
in the sense that you know what we say
is that if we have uh this g h proxy
convex function we know that g will
always be at least as small as uh h
and so what if we try to reverse that in
saying that we have some objective g
that we want to minimize
can we construct some objective function
f such that it is proxy convex with g
being the proxy function
uh if we can do that then we've found an
efficient procedure for minimizing g all
we have to do is gradient descent on f
and so i think this kind of
reversing this uh
this procedure leads to possibly some
new and interesting ways to minimize
non-convex objectives like g
by constructing some surrogate
objectives f and then performing
gradient descent on f
um and so in the paper we also introduce
this other notion of proxy
non-convexity in the form of a proxy pl
inequality um don't really have time to
get into that but if you'd like to hear
more um please just feel free to come up
to me in the gather town
um and yeah i think i'm right up about
five minutes so thanks for listening
thanks spencer
any questions for spencer while uh adil
salim sets up
all right so the next speaker is adil
saleem
we don't hear you adult
yeah we can't hear you a deal
and now it's better
yes it's better there's just a bit of a
friction but go ahead let's see how it
goes
okay
all right
so you should see my screen
okay so i'm going to talk about
decentralized optimization and in
particular about the optimal algorithm
for the case for a special case of
decentralized optimization and this is a
joint work with geometric of 11
so what do we want to do so in modern
machine learning we have to deal with
large models and um and we can refactor
these problems as a large-scale
optimization problems
so typically we have a network of
computing agents
at each node of the network is located a
computing unit
and the goal of the network of computing
agents is to run a machine learning
algorithm
in a decentralized fashion
so what does it mean
mathematically so we can reformulate the
open canopy often we formulate this
problem as an optimization problem so
um so what we want to do is to minimize
uh the sum of the functions f i okay the
sum of the functions f i
uh distributively across the noise and
in this work we assume that the function
f i's are
smooth
and that numbers only convex
so what does it mean to solve this
problem the
[Music]
distributively across across the nodes
so first of all local computations will
be allowed so it means that at each node
so as i said that each node is located
in computing units
and essentially this computing unit has
access to local variable x i
and the local cost function f i and the
computing unit is allowed to compute the
gradient of f i at x i
moreover in the network uh we are
allowed to perform some uh some
communication steps
which essentially means that uh the the
the local variable which is located at
i can be shared with the nodes uh with
the nodes which are connected to the
node i okay so for instance at x6 at
node 6 we have x6 and it can be shared
with uh with the node 2 and the node 1.
mathematically
communication rounds are represented by
multiplying
the the vector of the local variables so
the vector of the x i's
by a biomatrix k which is called the
coefficient matrix and a classical
example of a good so basic matrix
must satisfy some some
some properties but the classical
example of a concept matrix is the
laplacian of um of the of the of the
graph of the network
so if you multiply uh for instance the
portion of the network um
by the
by the vector of the local variables x i
what will happen is that the x i will be
uh
will be shared across the edges of the
network
so now what we want to do is to study
the complexity of a decentralized
decentralized algorithm
so this complexity will be um
will be
in terms of the number of local
computations so computations of the
greatest of f i and number of
communication rounds which means
mathematically multiplications by the
gaussian matrix k
to achieve absolute accuracy
and this complexity will be different in
terms of the problems one of the
problems data
which are essentially the
condition number of of the functions of
the local construction f i which is uh
the ratio between the smoothness
constant and the strong convexity
parameter and the condition number of
the gossip matrix
which is the ratio between the the
maximum eigenvalue of the gossip matrix
with the minimum positive
eigenvalue of the basic matrix
so this defines capability
and we have some lower bonds for the
complexity
of a decentralized algorithm in the in
the smooth straining convex case we know
that
we need at least quality of gamma
logarithmism one of our absolute local
computations and square root of kappa
key logged one over epsilon
communication communication rounds to
achieve epsilon accuracy
and what we did in this in this work is
to propose an optimal algorithm for this
for this problem
so an algorithm matching the the lower
bounds
and this algorithm is obtained by um
by uh by taking
what is called primary algorithm and
accelerating it using two techniques so
the first technique
is acceleration
so which is a
technique to accelerate optimization
algorithms and the second technique is
temperature acceleration which is a
technique to to accelerate the
resolution of
in our systems so
so basically uh these two techniques can
be applied and this way you obtain the
the optimal algorithm so i do not have
time to explain uh
the math but um
[Music]
let me just mention some future
directions so of course we need to go
beyond strong convexity because this
work is about strong convex strongly
convex local cost functions
also another important problem in
machine learning so of course
optimization can formalize several
machine learning
problems but we also have
the task of something that that is
fundamental in machine learning
so uh an interesting direction would be
to study
decentralized sampling problems
and finally
i said that we obtained an optimal
algorithm for for the problem which is
true but but in practice the problems
have uh they have more structure
so perhaps we can do better than by by
by specifying the structure of the
problems and the algorithms that we want
to study so for instance in federated
learnings there are some special
structure in the programs and perhaps we
can we can do better by by including the
structure in the problem that we study
thank you
thanks adele
our next speaker is makran sinha
any questions for adil wild macron said
sir
i'll ask a quick question adele is it is
is your algorithm related to like
belief propagation or something or is it
just like superficially look like a
message passing algorithm
you said
like belief propagation like uh
i don't know some of these sorts of like
loopy like message passing algorithms
for graphics uh yes actually so as i
said uh yes so actually uh something
that is hidden in the presentation is
that you know this uh
acceleration
uh it's a way to accelerate the
communication in the network
okay so instead of using
instead of coming
at each step
instead of communicating
instead of communicating the message
from from the current node to its
neighbor then you do several
several communication steps so that the
message goes further in the network oh
right yeah you get some yeah you go back
a few more steps i guess yeah cool
thanks
next speaker
hi can you give my slides yes
hi so i'm macron and i'm a semester
berkeley postdoctoral fellow and i will
talk about maximal advantage for quantum
query algorithms
so the main question here is sort of
understanding the power of quantum
computing especially in relation to
long-term uh uh perspectives because we
know that quantum algorithms can do
certain um tasks that we don't know how
to do classically like factoring large
integers but there's still a lot
that we don't know about what can we do
with it in the long term
one aspect of this question is you know
designing better quantum algorithms but
the other aspect which is often much
harder is to rule out all classical
algorithms just to solve your problems
at least in an efficient way
so here in this talk i will talk about
this question in the model of query
complexity which is a simplified model
where
you can understand these questions in a
rigorous way
so let me introduce this model so this
model the algorithm gets the input as a
black box
and it can access the input by making
queries to the input
so for instance a classical algorithm in
this model
it can use random bits to query bits of
the input
and
the answer is that particular bit of the
input
and the goal of the algorithm is to sort
of compute some function of the input it
is interested in
and to minimize number of queries
simultaneously
so here we're sort of making a
simplifying assumption that the most
expensive part of the algorithm is
really interacting with the black box
and that computation
so sort of that is the number of queries
is serving as a proxy for our running
time
and all the other operations the
algorithm does there they don't cost as
much so we're not counting them
so in this model you can sort of compute
any function with n queries because you
can access the entire input so the
maximum running time in this setting is
at most n
so this is what a classical algorithm
does and it's also has another name i
mean this is the same as a decision tree
uh query algorithm first square is a bit
x1 and depending on that it chooses
another bit to query and so on
so this is exactly what a decision tree
does
and so these are completely equivalent
so quantum algorithm is essentially the
same as a quantum analog of decision
tree just allowed to make more powerful
queries which are called superposition
queries
so now instead of squaring
for a bit it can query input bits in a
superposition
and the answer is also given back in a
superposition
and sort of this is a very very natural
uh model to understand quantum
algorithms because essentially almost
all known quantum algorithms they fit in
this framework including famous ones
like grover search or shores factoring
algorithm
and so far the rigorous guarantees we
have about them especially when
comparing them to classical uh most of
them uh are proven in this model of very
complexity
so now in this talk i want to ask the
question of you know what's the maximal
separation you can have
between the number of quantum and
classical queries needed to solve the
same task
so what is the task that gives the
quantum algorithms the maximal advantage
in this model
so this is uh
been studied since the early days of
quantum computing from the 90s
and prior to our work the best
separation was
constant versus n to the two thirds
meaning that there is a quantum
algorithm which can solve the problem
with only constant number of queries
but classically it requires reading n to
the two thirds uh making n to the two
thirds queries to the input
and what we show in our work that nikhil
bunsel is that sort of a certain problem
that is called k-fold for relation
gives a constant versus almost linear
separation
so essentially n is the maximum running
time in this model so this is
in some sense the best separation you
can hope for between quantum and
classical algorithms
and this was conjectured uh to be the
best possible separation this problem
k-fold for relation by anderson and
ambinus and uh in our paper we showed
this
and let me also mention that there was
independent work showing
essentially the same separation for a
related problem
so
let me in the last 30 seconds just tell
you one uh key idea that sort of went
into proving this and it's about and
understanding what makes quantum
algorithms different from classical
algorithms
so haven't told you what this k-fold
correlation problem is but it's about
computing the value of a certain degree
k multi-lane for long
and k is constant for us it's a constant
degree polynomial in many variables
and one feature this polynomial has is
that quantum algorithms can compute it
very efficiently with just constant
number of queries
but now we want to say that classical
algorithms cannot compute this constant
degree polynomials even if they make
lots of query
for this our main contribution is to
show that sparse polynomials even if
they have very high degree they cannot
solve this problem k-fold correlation
and it's one way
and one key distinguishing feature
between quantum and classical is that
classical models can
somehow compute only sparse polynomial
in a certain sense
and there's a lot of nice mathematical
ideas that went into proving this
including stochastic calculus for
analysis
and these sorts of some of these tools
are more common in optimization and
approximation algorithms and
they
they help a lot in solving this problem
so i will leave it at that thank you
very much
thanks makranth
any questions for makarandwa kevin said
sir
all right uh next speaker is kevin tm
cool um can people hear me okay yes
awesome
uh hey everyone uh thanks so much for
coming and uh to my lightning talk and
my name is kevin and i'm a final year
phd student at stanford university uh
today i'm going to talk about an
exciting line of work which focuses on
bringing
advances in robust statistics to
practical fruition using stp techniques
so this is based on several joint works
with my wonderful collaborators pictured
here um i want to give a special shout
out to cherry lee for helping introduce
me to to this research area and he's a
collaborator on all the works i'll
mention
okay
um so my research interest is
understanding fundamental challenges in
modern data science through an
algorithmic lens uh these challenges are
often simultaneously statistical and
computational in nature where we both
want to have good estimation or learning
rates from limited samples and also
don't want to use too many computational
resources such as time to space
to solve these problems i often have to
combine new iterative methods which are
tools for harnessing the data as
effectively as possible
with high dimensional statistics
insights which try to understand the
geometry of the data
okay so concretely i'll focus on robust
statistics today as a microcosm of
splendid techniques to set the stage in
classical ml and statistics we want to
perform some kind of learning task from
samples these tasks are typically
information theoretically possible
unless we assume some regularity about
the problem such as learning from
independent draws from a suitably nice
distribution
in many modern settings this is maybe
too much to hope for this is where
robust statistics comes into play where
we want to design estimators or learners
beyond this nice iod setting
so i study robust learning under the
strong contamination model where nature
first draws n independent samples from
an underlying distribution d
and then an adversary can inspect these
samples and replace an arbitrary epsilon
fraction of your choice with anything in
the support
so we receive the corrupted data but we
still want to estimate something about d
this is a powerful contamination model
which captures problems like data
poisoning and training deep neural nets
as well as model specification where the
generative model is only close to being
a well-behaved distribution
okay so for a long time uh the only
estimator is known for robust estimation
under strong contamination ran in
exponential time in the dimension so
it's a very challenging problem
uh recent breakthroughs gave the first
polynomial time algorithms and these
often follow the filtering paradigm
which i'll describe here
so we'll use mean estimation as a
running example where under the strong
contamination model we want to estimate
the trimming
and the first step of filtering is to
answer an identifiability question which
says okay maybe i can't right i don't
know how to robustly learn but can i at
least tell you when my data set is
tampered with like something's wrong
for example it turns out that whenever
the empirical mean is a bad estimate for
this mean estimation setting the
covariance must be larger than it should
be in some direction
so we can actually use this fact as a
certificate of corruption which lets us
design scores for filtering the basic
idea is that the certificate proves that
the bad points must be responsible for
this certificate like large variance so
we can down weight based on correlation
with the top eigenvector while
preserving most of the good points
okay so we can use this to design a
downward scheme in polynomial time by
making sure the filter removes some
point in every iteration but in high
dimensions maybe polynomial time is
still too slow
right so can we do better
so semi-definite taking taking a
side detour semi-definite programming or
sdp is a generalization of linear
programming to matrix-based constraints
and objectives so it turns out that
since what we're looking for is
basically ways to decrease the
covariance operator norm the ftp
community has design tools for exactly
this purpose
so a popular stp solving approach called
matrix multiplicative weights rephrases
stp as a gain
where we receive some gain matrices gt
and the algorithm plays responses yt
with trace one which yield this sort of
regret bound
by setting these game matrices g to be
empirical covariances this is actually
exactly what we wanted in robust
statistics so maximizing the left hand
side of this regret bound overall trace1
matrices u
exactly corresponds to bounding the
empirical covariance operator norm
okay so roughly our scores used to be
trace products with a tensor top
eigenvector of
gt
and matrix multiplicative weights
suggest that we instead use trace
products through this y key instead
which ends up being some kind of smooth
version of a top eigenvector that can
capture multiple directions at
once and by using filtering to decrease
these inner products with yt
and fast numerical linear algebra to
compute approximate scores we can we're
also in great shape to decrease the
regret bounce right hand side
okay so some straightforward
calculations show that as long as we
successfully filter each round we can
repeatedly have the covariance operator
norm in roughly log the iterations so
the whole algorithm terminates in
polylog rounds of filtering and this is
new
cool
so it turns out that this perspective on
using lightweight optimization
techniques to speed up learning
algorithms based on identifiability
proofs is very powerful
and it applies to a bunch of other tasks
including learning mixture models pca
and stochastic optimization
for each we give nearly linear time
algorithms with near optimal statistical
guarantees by designing custom iterative
methods which can harness the geometry
of the problem so each one of these has
its own story which i can't do justice
to on one slide so i'm happy to go into
more details during questions or offline
there's also a lot of exciting work to
be done in this area still so i'm happy
to talk about that as well
and thanks so much for your attention i
hope you enjoyed my talk and here are
links to the papers if you're interested
thanksgiving our next speaker is melanie
webber can can everyone see my slides
yes
thanks melanie
great
um so i'm going to talk about romanian
optimization um
so i'm going to talk about remaining
optimization and the work in this area
is motivated by the following
observation so in many applications
we encounter non-euclidean data this can
be in the form of graphs strings or
matrices
and in such settings it can be
beneficial to represent the data in
on a manifold so in a non-euclidean
space as opposed to using a standard
vector space setting
and this is particularly interesting if
this different geometric lens gives us
some nice algorithmic properties so for
instance related to geodesic convexity
and the class of problems that
is the the subject of this talk is
constraint optimization so here we have
a function defined on a romanian
manifold and we want to find its minimum
subject to constraints
this is a challenging problem um with
the currently existing tools in reminion
optimization because that field has
mostly focused on on unconstrained
optimization uh so in my joint work with
software who's at mit we looked into
designing algorithms that can directly
handle constraints
so we can start by getting some
intuition about the from the euclidean
setting where this problem has been
studied for for several decades already
and they're essentially two approaches
that people have considered
the first one are projected gradient
methods which are essentially extensions
of the gradient descent algorithm to
constrain settings
so here we perform a classical gradient
descent update
which may carry us out of the feasible
region and then we compute a projection
back onto the feasible region to ensure
that our update stays feasible
now depending on the geometry of our
constraints
computing such projections could
potentially be expensive and in such
cases
it's better to use a projection free
method
projection-free methods are
guaranteed to stay feasible without any
projection
step and and we ensure this by uh first
computing a subroutine which is called
the linear oracle
and this separation gives us a point in
the feasible direction which just
fulfills the constraints so in our
example here that's a point on the
boundary and then we linearly
interpolate between our current iterate
and that point and then step with a
certain step size um along that line
now if we move this idea to the
brim onion setting um we can write down
a generalized um
linear oracle so a generalized
separating which has the same
algorithmic idea and then instead of
performing that linear interpolation we
are now constructing a geodesic with the
the starting point being our current
iterate and then the endpoint being that
point
said k that is returned from from our
linear oracle
and this romanian equivalent of the
frank wolf algorithm
recovers similar convergence guarantees
to what we have for its euclidean
counterpart so in particular if our
objective function is geodesically
convex so that's convexity in the in the
romanian setting then we get a global
sublinear convergence rate
so as i said that is
exactly the same complexity as what we
get for the euclidean frank wolf
algorithm and that's also comparable to
what a remaining gradient descent would
achieve
so if we encounter and practice
constrained with monument optimization
task and we have to decide which
algorithm to use it really comes down to
investigating how expensive is it to
compute a projection and compare that to
how expensive it is to solve that that
separating that linear oracle
so that
can be quite challenging in
in general because the the subroutine is
actually non-convex so one
approach that we could take is to
numerically estimate
um
to numerically approximate a solution to
that linear oracle and then we can show
if that approximation is reasonably good
then we can retain those uh global
sublinear convergence guarantees
and the more interesting case are our
special
cases and
specific riemannian manifolds where we
can actually solve this in closed form
and in such cases um this
renders the algorithm into a very
practical algorithm
and and i want to show one example where
this is possible so if we take the
manifold of symmetric positive definite
matrices
and we impose interval constraints
then we can solve this in in closed form
so one
practical example where we encountered
this is the the karcher mean problem
which asks us to compute an average over
a set of symmetric positive definite
matrices
and that is a problem that is non-convex
through the euclidean lens but
geodesically convex to the through the
remaining lens so one example where this
translation to the remaining setting
really gives us some some benefits
and then i also want to show some some
brief numerical uh results for this
problem um so here we see the the rimani
and frank wolf algorithm that i showed
you in in plu and then also to other
variants that i
didn't get to cover
and if you look through those plots you
see that
for different sets of parameters we
significantly outperform
state-of-the-art methods due to this
nice practical algorithm with the clause
from solution of the linear oracle thank
you
thank you melanie
our next speaker is alex wayne any
questions for melanie while alex sets up
i don't see any
hey can you hear me okay yes
um okay i'll go ahead and start then
um
let's make sure the slides are working
um okay so let me jump right in and
tell you a bit about the settings so
let's uh sort of imagine that we want to
extract some kind of a hidden signal
from a large noisy data set this is a
fairly generic setup that we might
imagine we encounter in practice and so
how do we design the best possible
algorithms for this type of task
well there's a few criteria we're
probably interested in
we'd like to have statistical efficiency
meaning that we can find the signal even
if it's weak
or maybe equivalently that we need you
know the least amount of data possible
or fewest number of samples possible
and on the other hand we also care about
computational
efficiency we want the fast runtime so
that we can scale this to
huge problems
but actually it's sometimes
fundamentally impossible to achieve both
of these goals simultaneously
and so i'm interested in determining
which types of trade-offs are possible
so here's kind of a concrete toy example
for this kind of setup so imagine that
the data is a random n vertex graph
let's say every edge occurs with
probability one half
and now the signal part is a clique
planted on k vertices that just means i
connect all of those vertices to each
other like the ones shown in red here
and so the goal is that i give you this
graph you need to find clique
and so
you know this problem is believed to
have this striking phenomenon we call a
statistical computational gap
so um here we're plotting k which is the
clique size you can kind of think of it
as a signal-to-noise ratio so when the
clique is extremely small it's simply
statistically impossible to find it
if the clique is quite big bigger than
square root n then we know an efficient
algorithm a polynomial time algorithm to
find it but then in the middle there's
this very large
hard regime which is more elusive so
here
you can find the clique if you're
willing to sort of do a brute force
search over all possibilities but we do
not know any polynomial time algorithm
and these types of gaps are actually
ubiquitous
all kinds of problems sparse pca
community detection etc etc um you know
many types of problems inspired by
practice
have these sort of conjectured hard
regimes that we would like to understand
um okay and so
you know how can we be sure the hard
regime is actually hard
um
maybe it's fundamentally hard or maybe
we just need to find a more clever
algorithm
and so worst case complexity theory like
np hardness actually won't really help
us here because these are average case
problems with random input right just
because max clique is np hard it doesn't
mean i can't solve
planted clique on a random input
and so we need a way to prove or argue
about computational hardness of
statistical problems
and why do we want to do this well a few
reasons is because it can tell us when
to stop looking for a better algorithm
it can predict which problems are likely
to have better algorithms than the ones
we currently know and it can give us
even some guidance of what a better
algorithm should look like
and so you know how actually do we
prove or give evidence that problems are
hard
well one common approach is to
show unconditional lower bounds against
some restricted class of algorithms so
we propose some large class of
algorithms that we believe are maybe
sort of optimal
and we
rule those out and so
proposals for this class of algorithms
um a bunch have been made so here are a
few of them listed
but i want to talk about a different
proposal that's more recent called
low-degree polynomial algorithms
i won't even try to formally define what
this class of algorithms is although
it's a bit what it sounds like and you
can read on the slide here
as well
but in the last minute or so let me try
to convince you why i think
this low degree polynomial algorithms
are a very sort of promising and
exciting
um you know avenue for understanding
these kinds of problems so there's two
reason really the first is that it is
actually tractable to prove failure of
all of these algorithms
um for for various problems
and
in fact the proofs are somewhat user
friendly and so can be broadly applied
to you know whatever your favorite
problem might be
and we often can prove optimal results
really proving that um you know these
algorithms fail all the way up to this
conjectured
hard
phase
and then on the other hand these lower
bounds are sort of meaningful because
these low degree polynomial algorithms
actually do capture the best known
algorithms for a whole slew of different
statistical problems
i won't try to get into the subtleties
of exactly what i can consider a
statistical
problem
but i do sort of believe that they have
a better track record than these
previous frameworks that i mentioned
and somehow why this happens is because
low degree polynomials do capture a
bunch of concrete classes of known
powerful algorithms like spectral
methods approximate message passing
things that typically yield the optimal
algorithms for things so if we can rule
out low degree polynomials we can also
rule out a bunch of these concrete
approaches
and so
now these low degree
lower bounds are actually fairly
widespread
originally
they were introduced for the hypothesis
testing problems so these papers here
were really the ones that first came up
with this idea of looking at low degree
polynomials
and much of my recent work has been
about extending this uh theory to not
just hypothesis testing but all kinds of
different statistical problems so maybe
recovering the signal optimizing random
functions uh refutation and
certification
um
all right and so i will leave you with a
few references if you'd like to know
more yeah thanks a lot
thank you alex
um any questions for alex while angela
sets up
uh our next speaker is uh angela zoo
hi i'll be talking today about stateful
offline contextual policy evaluation and
learning this is joint work with nathan
kalas my postdoc here at fodzy and
simon's next semester um so this project
let me summarize as
it's trying to find the class of markov
decision processes or dynamic programs
for which our recent progress and causal
inference and single time slip causal
inference
can actually solve quite well so first
let me provide some exposition on single
time step causal inference and this
research program on heterogeneous
treatment effects
um so single time step cause inference
is the setting on the left
i'm going to assume that i have some
data sets of x covariates a actions or
treatments and outcomes why only for the
treatments that are historically
administered in the data set and so the
key problem in causal inference is that
of off policy evaluation or learning so
i have the status that these treatments
were given suboptimally and i want to
assess what is the causal impact of
deploying an improved algorithm and how
do i therefore optimize to find the best
algorithm for assigning treatments to
individuals to maximize my causal
outcomes
so the data of course reflects this
fundamental missingness pattern
nonetheless why can't i just take
averages um in treatment components to
estimate effects of policies well it's
because a is actually correlated with
outcomes in my data set so if treatments
were assigned by some algorithm that
algorithm was optimized for some target
and so therefore treatments will be
correlated with outcomes um in the
observational data so that's single time
step causal inference there's been a lot
of progress in heterogeneous treatment
effects where i assume that individual
responses to treatment may actually vary
in a way that is predictable from
covariates
i'm going to talk today about a class of
sequential dynamic programs that's quite
common in operations research and which
is solvable by single time step causal
inference so what is different about
this class of dynamic programs an
example is allocating
interventions to improve
homelessness for different individuals
but also considering additional capacity
constraints
so the key difference structure is that
i'm going to expand the state of a
dynamic program and i'm going to
consider a setting that can be thought
of as offline contextual bandits so i
have iid arrivals of individuals they
have a causal response and
given their causal response then i know
deterministically what the state
transitions are so this is a a very
common model actually for for many
practically
deployed algorithms and operations
research you may not be so interested in
the specific problem so what is
interesting about this is just
understanding how the causal structure
of data changes the algorithms or
control policies that we might be
interested in
um so let me give talk more about the
problem set up this is very insights
driven project in the sense that once i
set it up this becomes more obvious in
hindsight because i'm just reading off
the causal structure of the data so
a markov decision process there is some
state from which i take an action and
then i transition to the next state the
the key specialization in in this is
that the transition probability is being
given by a causal model from this
individual
x denotes covariates for individuals
which arrive ied so this is the kind of
offline contextual banded nature of the
problem once i observe the response of
the individual i deterministically know
how the system transitions
but the kind of key argument here
and i'll illustrate this as an example
is that in this class of problems
suppose that the causal response is
conditionally independent of the system
state so i'll illustrate this for the
case of airline revenue management or
dynamic pricing
so um there's a lot of algorithms that
have been successfully deployed in this
context um and the the assumption
corresponds to the whether or not you
purchase an airline ticket at a given
price is independent of the number of
seats left on the plane which is the
system state known to the decision maker
once you condition on the price that is
being given so that's the kind of key
assumption and if your problem setup
satisfies that assumption then your
problem is as hard as single time step
causal inference so what do we do we do
some modeling our key insight is that
you can estimate expectations over a
single arrival by reusing data from all
arrivals and and that is what i'll call
single timestep causal inference i won't
go into the details about estimation
it's in the paper
but what are our key improvements i
would say our key improvements are if
you apply generic
dynamic program or offline reinforcement
learning ideas you will incur this
dependence on
horizon many additional nuisance
functions to estimate um on the other
hand by specializing into the problem
structure you you recover the kind of
right dependence on the number of
nuisance estimates and this can help in
practice so just to summarize our
results we study the sample complexity
you do get some improvements by pulling
the data of course we have a problem
structure dependent sharp
characterization of error amplification
which establishes that confounding
matters even in these more simplified
dynamic programs i won't talk about the
results but this helps in practice
compared to trying to apply generic rl
that is not
tailored for this problem structure so
i'll just conclude there and say thanks
thank you thanks angela
any questions for angela
i don't see any
uh thanks thanks to all the fellows for
a quite uh intense and informative
session um
the next uh item on the agenda is we'll
hear from our program organizers uh but
let's take a three minute quick three
minute break before that and we'll
resume the session at 12 22
uh and we'll hear from all our program
organizers and all the activities that
are going at sam's semester this year
and
see you at 12 22.